ok para este experimento vamos a crear
una base y para eso vamos a necesitar un
pedazo de cartón pegando una pulgada y
media en cada orilla después lo cubrimos
con un mantel plástico de mesa de color
negro y luego vamos a llenarlo con agua
aproximadamente unos tres cuartos de
pulgada
ahora voy a ponerle cinta a una lata
para después cortarla
claro usando unos guantes protectores y
voy a recortar para hacer una sola para
que podamos levantar eso permitirá que
escape el calor de una vez
ok entonces aquí tenemos a nuestra amiga
sushi que quiere llegar al otro lado
para encontrarse con sus amigos porque
quieren hacer algo juntos entonces ellos
están de este lado festejando yei
acabamos lo será genial entonces todos
están aquí echando relajo y dicen sus y
vamos apúrate vamos a ver una película o
algo y entonces sushi
si no se quedan quietos tienen muchos
problemas con eso
bueno este no se deja se va a quedar así
pero su psique está por acá dice hoy
desearía estar con mis amigos
así que ya quiere cruzar esto y estar
con sus amigos pero no se quiere mojar y
necesita encontrar una forma de poder
cruzar para estar con sus amigos
entonces termina pensando en todas las
cosas que tiene y resulta que tiene una
vela una vela pequeña y una lata a esta
es una lata cualquiera de refresco
entonces ella dice ah ah tengo una vela
y tengo una lata entonces modifica la
lata que tiene un poco de agua
pero no pasa nada entonces modifica la
lata y quiere y quiere usar la lata para
poder cruzar el agua rápidamente así que
hizo este barco térmico y usará la vela
adentro de la lata y quiere ver si puede
cruzar el estanque para poder estar con
todos sus amigos
ok entonces va a prender la vela para
empezar a liberar un poco de esa energía
potencial química que se convertirá en
energía cinética y esa energía cinética
sale en forma de calor entonces ese
calor
básicamente provoca que el aire que se
encuentra alrededor de la vela se
expanda entonces ella se sube en el
dispositivo en la lata y veamos si puede
llegar va a probar si la vela tiene
suficiente energía para llevarla al otro
lado del estanque
y parece que sí ahí va
entonces lo que sucede es que el aire
frío está pasando a través de la lata y
es calentado por la vela se expande
empujando así el velero térmico que es
la solapa y sale hacia atrás eso provoca
que la lata se mueva hacia adelante y
logre cruzar el estanque así es como
nuestra amiga sushi se encuentra con
todos sus amigos
hola chicos y ellos le dicen a su barco
regresa al otro lado y ellos ya pueden
tener una fiesta o ir al cine o hacer lo
que quieran